the justice con
stuff um putting it on is just
amazing and so I
was more than honored to do
whatever i could to
to participate
I'm gonna I may show a clip
and it is a small clip but oh i mean i
may what did i say
and uh also maybe there's another little
like a teeny little
kind of um another announcement as well
like a little
a little side thing just for the fans
the clip is...
that's gonna be fun
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going to be
my new justice league snyder cut video
zack snyder made a couple really big
announcements he did a really big
interview talking about the snyder cut
and what's going to be different
he revealed a bunch of new details so
we'll break it all down if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos
of course i'll be doing videos for all
the comic-con trailers that dropped this
week so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
all those videos when they post and i'll
do some cool comic-con giveaways during
those videos too
but i'll just number these as we go
along just to stay organized because the
interview that he did was really long
there were a bunch of things that he
talked about
first big thing like he says during the
clip that i attached to the beginning of
this
the stuff that he's going to be showing
off the footage this weekend is going to
be
saturday it's going to be really cool he
doesn't say exactly what's going to be
in the clip but he does make it sound
like it's going to be a pretty big deal
the last big clip that we got had a
bunch of dark side wonder woman stuff in
it as part of the dark side bits of the
movie that they're going to be adding
back in
just because darkseid really didn't
figure in to the theatrical cut at all
i've already talked about a lot of the
deleted scenes that we know were coming
back
in but because the snyder cut is going
to be so much longer with so much
different footage and story lines
there's still a lot of stuff that we
don't know yet
he also reveals that while that's
happening they're going to be making a
special announcement for the fans he
made a joke about that like oh you know
everything is kind of supposed to be for
the fans
but the way he talks about the
quote-unquote special announcement
makes it sound like it's going to be
some new character that he's revealing
is going to show up
i know people have been hoping for
martian manhunter it could be something
else
it could be a special green lantern
announcement because that's the other
big character that people are hoping to
see show up
you're welcome canada i just did a big
video about the alternate ending that we
found out about
originally zack snyder had planned for a
big green lantern post credit scene in
his cut of the movie
he'll also probably formally announce an
even bigger version of the trailer at
the dc fandom comic con panel in august
so this is going to be a lot of dc comic
con related panels happening this summer
just one of those is happening this
weekend for the justice league snyder
cut
all the other dc movies including
another justice league snyder cut panel
will happen in august
if you've been wondering what all those
teasers that dc dropped recently for dc
fandom comic con that's what that stuff
is for the next big thing he talked
about during this was a more evil black
suit superman scenes that he's adding
back into the movie he talks about
wanting superman to go on more of a
character journey in terms of
reconciling his morality his
place on earth his relationship with
lois lane a human
and how that relationship affects the
way he relates to humanity
and how watching superman grapple with
those things makes him a more relatable
character
how he's trying to take superman to the
pinnacle of what he can be
through batman v superman man of steel
and justice league considering he's been
on this character arc since the man of
steel movie
but the whole thing with the evil black
suit version of superman that people
have been talking about that was taken
out of the theatrical cut
that stuff is there just to round out
his character arc to give it the full
dramatic weight that's kind of one of
the reasons why his arc didn't resonate
quite as much in the theatrical cut in
the fact that he really wasn't in the
movie that much
mostly because so much it was dedicated
to this subplot
with the black suit superman stuff he
talks a lot about ben affleck's batman
during the snyder cut
and especially during batman v superman
2 and how it focuses so much on bruce
wayne as opposed to just straight up
batman
obviously there's a lot of batman
running around in his batman costume
but a lot of our time with ben affleck's
batman has been with the bruce wayne
version of the character not so much
with batman
he even talked about how he's excited
for matt reeves in robert pattinson's
the batman 2021 movie next year he's
just super excited to see it and has
nothing but praise for matt reeves as a
filmmaker and he really likes robert
pattinson as batman
zack snyder is a really cool dude so you
expect him to say nice things about
other filmmakers but it is cool to see
him praise
matt reeve so much as a filmmaker i'm
not expecting to get a ton of footage
for the batman movie at the dc
fandom comic con panel in august just
because they've only been filming the
movie for a little while but they might
show off some sort of teaser or some
concept art or character reveals and
costumes like there's still a couple big
characters from the movie that we
haven't seen yet
the next big thing he talked about was
wonder woman and aquaman in the snyder
cut more their story is
loners having to find their place in
this new team all of a sudden
how they both have so much stuff going
on outside of what's happening during
the events of the movie
like wonder woman thinking about her own
future the way he talked about it wonder
woman is also thinking about her own
future inside the dceu reconciling with
themyscira and the other amazons after
having left so many years ago with steve
trevor
then all the stuff that aquaman is
grappling with him trying to figure out
his own future because he has to go
become king of atlantis after the events
during this movie
so remember that everything that happens
during the justice league snyder cut
still takes place before the aquaman
movie
but he also talked a lot about the
cyborg character during the snyder cut
and how
initially when they were first making
the movie they wanted to make him the
heart of the movie from the very
beginning
so apparently he has this huge arc
between where he's at at the beginning
of the movie and the end of the movie
and how he plays a really big role in
bringing the actual team together
that'd probably be one of the biggest
character turns from the theatrical cut
now zack snyder said that he hadn't seen
the theatrical cut but if you remember
in the theatrical version of the movie
wonder woman kind of had to drag him
along into the team so it sounds like
the snyder cut version of cyborg
is completely different the other really
big thing that he talked about that i
know everyone's been wondering about
is how the justice league snyder cut
fits into dceu
continuity like people are wondering is
this going to replace the theatrical cut
will the snyder cut be the new canon for
those characters going forward
we have to remember that a lot of the
new dc movies already take place
after the events of justice league so a
lot of the characters have already gone
off in their different directions like
wonder woman 3 will be set during
present day
after the events of justice league so
she'll be going off in her own direction
based on what patty jenkins wants to do
with that character
the way zack snyder talked about it he
talked about his movies like man of
steel batman v superman justice league
snyder cut
as the snyder verse being its own
self-contained thing even though
technically it is connected to the other
justice league movies that those
characters appear in
but the way he's thinking about it
himself as he's finishing this version
of the movie is that it's his own
special project
and the other directors come in and do
what they want with those characters
so obviously because he's finishing this
and it's kind of a different version of
the movie
after they do something like say the
aquaman movie which takes place after it
the stuff that happens with aquaman
during the snyder cut won't change
what's happening during the aquaman
movie i think i did a video a while ago
after the theatrical
came out because we knew about a lot of
the deleted scenes there was a giant
subplot with aquaman and volkow in
atlantis
during the snyder cut so we'll probably
see a lot of that footage come back in
for those of you that are hoping for a
really long version of the movie too
he did say that he was expecting it to
be way longer than initially reported
so early on he said it'd be probably
around four hours long
now he says it might actually wind up
being longer than that so the fact that
it seems like it's getting so much
longer just in terms of sheer run time
makes it more likely that they will wind
up releasing it as say like a couple
different episodes weekly instead of
just dropping an entire
four to five hour movie when they made
the initial announcement that they were
actually doing the project they said
there were a couple different release
schedules that warner brothers was
considering for hbo max
it was either going to be a traditional
just movie release like here's the new
cut of the movie everybody enjoy it
or they would wind up releasing it as a
different six part series just based on
the total run time they made a lot of
watchmen comic book comparisons like
breaking it up like you would break up
the watchmen comic book to different
episodes but each of those episodes run
times was kind of in question it would
just depend on how long the total run
time of the movie would be
in terms of release date most outlets
have been reporting spring 2021 which
would be sometime around
april may maybe early june just
depending on what happens in the next
six months
there's a lot of movies that we were
supposed to be seeing right now that
have now been delayed like christopher
nolan's tenant
just got removed from the release
schedule and they said that they have a
really weird
release plan for it around the world so
some of you that live outside the united
states will start getting movies and
theaters
before the united states does and if you
do live inside the u.s
we might start seeing movies in theaters
later this year in certain parts of the
country but maybe not
everywhere so while the movie release
schedule stuff for 2020 the rest of the
year is going to get way more confusing
before it gets simpler
but don't worry if there are any big
announcements about bigger movie release
dates of course i'll include that in my
videos
if we're just talking about dc movies
wonder woman 1984 is still supposed to
come out in october but they might wind
up changing that
i assume that they'll have some
announcements to make about that at the
big dc fandom comic con panels next
month
everyone let me know in the comments
though what are you most looking forward
to about the snyder cut i know everybody
just wants to see movies again
no matter how they release them if it's
going to be video on demand or movies
and theaters we just want to see
some new movies while you wait for
everything click here for my brand new
wonder woman 1984
trailer and learn about the special
prequel story they just released
and click here for that last big justice
league snyder cut trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!